si l'on n'était pas dans une boulangerie
artisanale où tout est fait maison on
pourrait presque dire on risque en la
contradiction qu'un jour d'épiphanie la
galette est fabriqué à pithiviers en
quantité industrielle
j'espère en vendre aux alentours des 250
j'espère j'espère peut-être plus
peut-être moins je sais pas du tout mais
voilà on pense entre 200 et 250 galette
aujourd'hui ce geste ancestral stéphane
maréchal le pratique depuis 25 ans au
quotidien pour la fabrication du
pithiviers feuilleter le jour de la
galette il y a quelques légères
modifications à faire concernant la
forme et le d5 dessus ne pas oublier la
fève bien sûr et pour le contenu c'est
la même chose
mais si c'est vrai que la crème d'amande
c'est quand même quelque chose de
particulier par rapport aux pithiviers
et du cou j'utilise la même recette en
fait que celle du pithiviers voilà donc
déjà on achète nos amandes entières on
les broie ici on a un broyeur on fait
notre propre poudre d'amande comme ça on
a un parfum qui est quand même nettement
nettement supérieur à la poudre
d'amandes qui existe souvent un commerce
qui est déjà tout le set ça n'a rien à
voir je trouve en arômes sa recette
stéphane maréchal pourrait en parler
pendant des heures mais la galette a
aussi quelque chose à nous dire quand on
la recouvre de sirop écouter
ce doux crépitements les clients ne
l'entendront pas mais leur présence en
masse devant la boulangerie prouve que
malgré les appels à la prudence du
gouvernement les français n'ont pas
renoncé aux réunions de famille pour la
tradition tout simplement et puis la
partager en famille également pour
terminer cette période de fêtes de fin
d'année voilà et bien commencer la
nouvelle année c'est jour de l'épiphanie
donc juste après noël c'est toujours la
guerre et qui arrive juste après les
plus chanceux auront la fève et la
couronne les boulangers eux ont déjà
leurs lauriers l'année dernière ils ont
terminé deuxième au concours de la
meilleure galette du loiret